in the last video i claimed that this
result we got for the area of a triangle
that had sides
of length a b and c i claimed that this
is equivalent to heron's formula and
what i want to do in this video is show
you that this is equivalent to heron's
formula by essentially just doing a
bunch of algebraic manipulation so the
first thing we want to do let's just
bring this one half c under the radical
sign so one half
c that's the same thing as the square
root of c squared over 4. you take the
square root of that you get one half c
so this whole expression is equal to
instead of drawing the radical i'll just
write the square root
of
this of c squared over 4
of c squared over 4 times all of this
times i'll just copy and paste it
times all of that
copy and paste
so times all of that and of course it
has to be distributed
it has to be distributed so c squared of
4 times all of that and then we have to
close the square root
and then
this thing
let me just distribute the c squared
over 4 this is going to be equal to the
square root
this is going to be hairy but i think
you'll find it satisfying to see how
this could turn into something as simple
as heron's formula the square root of c
squared over 4 times a squared is c
squared
a squared over 4
minus
c squared over 4
c squared over 4 i'm just distributing
this
times and i'm going to write it as the
numerator squared over the denominator
squared so times c squared
plus a squared minus b squared squared
over
over if i square the denominator that's
4c squared
for
c squared and we immediately see that c
squared and that c squared are going to
cancel out let me close all of the
parentheses just like that
and then and of course this 4 times that
4 that's going to result in let me write
it this way that's the same thing as 4
squared and i'm instead of writing 16
you'll see while i'm right why i'm
writing that
now this i can rewrite as
this i can rewrite this is going to be
equal to the square root i'm arbitrarily
switching colors of
c a over 2 squared c a over
2 squared this is the same thing as that
right i'm just writing it as the whole
thing squared if i squared that's the c
squared a squared over 2 squared over 4
minus
i'm going to write this whole thing as
an expression squared so that's
c squared plus a squared minus b squared
over
4
and we're squaring both the numerator
and the denominator we squared both the
numerator and the denominator
now this might look a little bit
interesting to you let me make the
parenthesis a slightly different color
you might remember from factoring
from factoring polynomials that if i
have something of the form x squared
minus y squared that factors into x plus
y
times x minus y and we're going to be
using this over and over again
now
if you call ca over 2x and you call this
whole big thing y then we have x squared
minus y squared so we can factor it so
this whole thing is going to be equal to
the square root
of
of
x plus y or in this case it's c a over 2
plus the y which is c squared plus a
squared minus b squared
over 4
times
x
minus y so this is our x
c a
over 2
minus
all of this business over here or even
better let me just say plus and then let
me just write the negative so plus
minus c squared minus a squared plus
b squared
all of that
over 4. so all i did here
all i did here is i said this is the
same thing as this plus this this plus
this times this
minus this this
minus i just put a multiplied i just
said plus the negative of this so minus
c squared minus a squared plus b squared
all i did is that right there
now let's see if we could simplify this
well if we could add these fractions
well we can get a common denominator ca
over 2 that's the same thing as 2 c a
over 4
c a over 2 that's the same thing as 2c a
over 4 just multiplying the numerator
and the denominator by 2. and now we can
add
we can add the numerators so our whole
expression is now going to be equal to
the square root
of
of
this first expression will become and
i'm going to write it this way i'm going
to write c squared
c squared
plus 2 c a plus 2 c a
plus a squared plus a squared
minus
b squared
all of that
over 4
that's our first expression
and then our second expression
is going to become well everything's
going to be over 4 so i'll just write
that right now everything over 4. so we
could write this as b squared
v squared
and then we could write this as b
squared
minus
b squared minus
c squared
minus 2 c a minus 2 c a
plus a squared plus a squared and just
make sure thing i think that i have a
minus a squared here plus times a minus
i have still it's a minus a squared i
have a plus 2 ca over here minus times a
minus that's plus 2ca i have a minus c
squared here i have a minus c squared
here so these two things are equivalent
now the next thing we need to recognize
or hopefully we can recognize is that
this over here
that over here this might get a little
bit messy that's the same thing as c
plus a squared let me write this this is
equal to the square root
the square root open parenthesis of
this over here is
c plus a
squared minus b squared
over four
that's that first term and then the
second term this over here is the same
thing as c minus a squared so that whole
thing will simplify to
b squared minus
c
minus a
squared all of that
all of that
over
4. so we're making some headway as i
told you this is a
hairy problem but we're seeing some neat
applications of factoring polynomials
and we're seeing how a fairly bizarre
looking equation can be transformed into
a simpler one
now we can use this exact same property
we have that pattern something squared
minus something else squared something
squared minus something else squared so
we can factor it out and i'll do it in
the same line so this is going to be
equal to
i'm going to write a little bit small
just so i don't run a space the square
root this will factor into
this plus this
so c
plus a
plus b
plus b
times c plus a minus b right it's this
exact same pattern that i did over here
this is x squared this is y squared so
times c plus
a
minus b
all of that
over 4
and then we have this one this is going
to be b
plus c minus a
so we're going to have b
plus c minus a let me scroll down to the
right a little bit
times
b
plus c minus a right that's x plus y
times b
minus c minus a or that's the same thing
as b
minus c plus a that's the same thing as
b minus this is the same thing as b
minus c minus a right
all right and all of that
all of that
over
4.
now i can rewrite this whole expression
i don't want to run out of space i can
rewrite this whole expression as
i could write well 4 is the product of 2
times 2
4 is a product of 2 times 2.
so our whole area expression has been i
arguably simplified to
it equals the square root and this is
really the home stretch
of this right here
which i could just write as
a plus b plus c over 2
that's that term right there
times
this term
times that term and let me write a
simplification here c plus a minus b
that's the same thing as a
plus b plus c
minus 2 b these two things are
equivalent right you have an a you have
a c and then b minus 2 b is going to be
equal to
minus b
right b minus 2b that's minus b so this
is going to be this next term is going
to be
a plus b plus c
minus 2b
over
2. or instead of writing it like that
let me write this over 2
minus this over 2.
and then our next term
right here
same exact logic
that's the same thing
as a plus b plus c
minus 2a
minus 2a all of that over 2. right if we
if we add the minus 2a to the a we get
minus a so we get b plus c minus a these
are identical things so all of this over
2 or we can split the denominators just
like that over 2.
and then one last term and you might
already recognize the rule of
heron's formula popping up
i was thinking not the rule of heron
heron's formula that term right there is
the exact same thing as
a plus b plus c
minus 2 c right you take you take 2c
away from the c you get a minus c and
then you still have the a and the b and
then all of that over two
write that over two minus that over two
and of course we're taking the square
root of all of this stuff
now
if we define
if we define an s
to be equal to a plus b plus c
over 2
then this equation simplifies a good bit
this right here is s
that right there is s that right there
is s
that right there is s and these and
these simplify a good bit too
minus two b
over two that's the same thing as minus
b
minus two a over two the same thing as
minus a
minus 2c over 2 the same thing as minus
c so this whole equation for our area
our area now becomes our area is now
equal to i'll rewrite the square root
the radical the square root
of s
that's that right there of s
times
i'll do the same colors times s
minus b
times s minus b
times this is s minus a
s
minus a
times and where the last one s minus c
s
minus e and we have proved heron's is
the exact same thing as what we proved
at the end of the last video so this was
pretty
pretty neat and we just had to do a
little bit of hairy algebra to
actually prove it